ça va bien excellent j'aimerais
commencer ma présentation avec une petit
sondage secret à main levée j'aimerais
savoir qui se considèrent aventuriers
ici aujourd'hui
v la main les aventuriers ok bon à peu
près le tiers de la salle qui est
aventurier excellent j'aimerais savoir
qui a des enfants à main levée au
plusieurs plus la moitié de la salle moi
j'ai deux enfants daniel qui a quatre
ans a dit li qui a 7 ans maintenant qui
a acheté une maison dans sa vie god qui
a changé au moins une fois travaillé
dans sa vie bord mais pas mal tout le
monde a levé la main au moins une fois
si vous avez levé la main pour moi vous
êtes aventuriers l'aventuré beaucoup
plus large qui le défi physique le
planeur ou le voyage l'avant tous à
chaque fois qu'on sort de notre zone de
confort à chaque fois qu'on brise notre
équilibre et qu'on fait un pas parent à
20 mais mon message que j'ai pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est osé laventure passe à
l'action
sortez de votre zone de confort mais
quand on sort de notre zone de confort
ben on vit des difficultés du doute
c'est pas toujours facile on est mieux
rester dans notre zone de confort mais
aujourd'hui j'ai ce message là où celle
aventure mais je vous donne un outil
supplémentaire
voyez la flèche en haut à droite ça
s'appelle lentilles doute landes où tu
sais quoi mais c'est l'art de réduire
nos objectifs en deux petites étapes
simples pour les rendre facilement
réalisable parce que plus on réduit
l'objectif un petit étape plus on se
rapproche seulement mandana de vie ou en
notre contrôle c'est pas le passé ses
poils foutu c'est le moment présent j'ai
commencé en est aventurier conférencier
13 ans d'autres avec une aventure qui
s'appelait la traversée du québec
enquête
je veux le faire 3500 km de kayak en
solitaire qu'est ce que le monde m'ont
dit quand je leur ai dit que je voulais
faire ça ce projet là qu'est ce qu'ils
m'ont dit
d vous serez s'y rend pas c'est pas
mourir mais moi je le disais que si
quelqu'un se coucher avec l'idée que mon
rêve était irréalisable
cette personne là j'allais me réveiller
avec les bruits que j'allais faire en
réalisant mon rêve
puis je me suis lancée
et
m
j'ai réussi pige pas marre au retour de
cette aventure là j'ai commencé à donner
des conférences et le plaisir que j'ai
prouvé à être sur scène devant vous bah
ça m'a donné le goût d'en faire mon
métier et à partir de ce moment là bas
mes aventures se sont multipliés à
travers le monde
je suis retourné dans l'ordre du canada
mais cette fois là c'était pour faire du
rafting en alaska avec mon amitié nom
inconnu les montagnes et grizzly en
europe j'ai donné plus de 200
conférences en amérique centrale avec ma
blonde on a connu les fonds marins on ne
connut la face cachée de la pauvreté un
autre tour on se marie on a eu notre
premier enfant et on a bâti la maison
nos rêves que voyez derrière nous là on
voulait bartis maison là on voulait la
dessiner nous mêmes on voulait acheter
le terrain on voulait couper lisant nous
mêmes les écorces et nous même tout
faire nous-mêmes sans aucune expérience
de construction en bois rond qu'est ce
que le monde on dit quand on leur a dit
qu'on voulait faire ça des fous celui ci
va pas fort et là dessus avait presque
raison en fait parce que ma femme a
accouché trois semaines avant le début
de la construction puis moi je ne savais
pas qu à partie ce moment là je
dormirais plus la nuit maison tu bosses
sauts comme un morceau de bois fois et
cloud une vie sainte foy bas c'est ce
qu'on a fait
mais c'est pas toujours facile de
réussir elf avec l'arrivée des enfants
dans nos vies à mes projets ont changé
sont devenus un peu plus court mais
peut-être aussi un peu plus intense dans
l'activité 2010
j'ai fait un film dure des heures sur
l'alaska en paramoteur 2011
j'ai voulu courir un marathon par jour
cinq jours semaine
pendant cette semaine 33 marathon pour
amasser des fonds pour opération enfant
soleil 2012 mais s'est fait larguer dans
ce québec sans coeur sans nourriture
riche en gps il fallait que je revienne
à utilisation par mes propres moyens
sa prise au jour et autres tables
servent à l'attraction c'est le sport
que je le plus pratiqué à l'entraînement
des fois quand brise notre équilibre on
peut aussi tomber
et donc j'ai osé l'aventuré
tranquillement d'une année à l'autre
d'une aventure à l'autre et j'ai bâti ma
confiance
l'antidote hisse au rang ont pas atteint
des objectifs très audacieux dans vie
mais il fau les atteindre une étape à la
fois tranquillement on bâtit notre
confiance on fait nos devoirs et on peut
réaliser des grands projets j'ai eu un
autre projet en tête que je suis venu
vous parler aujourd'hui une aventure
assez folle surtout pour un gars qui
your pas d'expérience polaire je voulais
aller en antarctique le continent le
plus froid sur terre le plus haut sur
terre le plus des articles le plus
venteux le moins habitées et je sais que
pour vous ça fait probablement j'irai
pas j'y réponds je répondrai pas mais
pour moi c'était le contraire elle j'ai
décidé d'y aller mais d'utiliser mon
anti doute d'y aller une étape à la fois
mais moi le zéro expérience pour l'un
conséquent m'indiquant que j'ai dit au
monde que je voulais faire ça pour
mourir mais j'avais appris depuis
plusieurs années que c'est pas aux
autres de décider ce que moi je suis
capable de faire
ben je me suis lancé dans ce projet puis
j'ai fait mes devoirs y travailler du
mieux que je pouvais à chacun des
instants
je
cette aventure-là a été au delà de mes
limites au delà de tout ce que j'avais
pu expérimenter en fred aventure oui
j'ai connu une fois le froid extrême
mon traîneau s'est brisé au 7e jour
traîneau que j'ai dû réparer encore et
encore à chaque fois que la température
descend dessaoulé - 35is brisait comment
j'ai fait les réparations comment j'ai
progressé à travers ces épreuves là je
suis allé un peu à la fois netapp à la
fois agir fait montrer nos seins points
de suture à la fois pour réussir à
progresser à travers cette aventure
l'antarctique c'est un endroit ce que tu
vaux pour apprendre c'est un endroit qui
est très cruel la mort et j'aimais pas
très loin mais pourtant j'ai des enfants
mais l'idée c'était de le faire du mieux
que je pouvais il sent dépassé mes
limites mes capacités que je connaissais
sa m'emmener au 28e jour
28e jour ace à progresser bien là
j'avais vécu un bon début d' aventure
j'étais en avance sur mon oreille malgré
que j'avais été obligé de changer mon
traîneau 28e jour où il est arrivé la
pire affaire qui peut arriver à
quelqu'un qui fait une expédition en
antarctique avec des serveurs
j'ai perdu le vin perdu devant une
journée c'est comme des vacances deux
jours tisba c'est comme une fin de
semaine
mais quand tu perds le vent pour neuf
jours ça devient plus dur je peux vous
garantir que l'antarctique c'est
l'endroit le plus bruyant sur terre
quand une tempête qui vend 250 lots
mettra messi aussi l'endroit le plus
silencieux ce temps ou presque
voilà bon deux jours 120 je me suis
reposé au troisième jour là je me suis
dit bon mais je vois le traîner mon
traîneau m et 95 kg à 3700 mètres
d'altitude en montant une pente à des
températures de moins 45 avec des bosses
sur le chemin habillée en hausse c'est
devenu difficile très difficile
vous avez vu j'ai couru de marathon dans
ma vie donnée - choix entre courir un
marathon ou faire trois heures de ski
dans ces conditions là elle choisit de
marathon la seule chose c'est que
c'était pas trop aux heures de ski qui
se ferait par jour 7 et 8
c'est devenu d'ici c'est devenu souffre
à la fatigue s'est installée le doute
s'est installé
et tranquillement le doute se
transformer en pensée est catastrophique
bien par du mois ma plus grande part
dans vie c'est pas byzance est pas le
vin c'est pas la solitude non mais plus
grand père envie c'est de ne pas être là
pour les personnes que j'aime si jamais
ils ont besoin de moi le validité cave
totale en date article oui mais je pense
les choses peuvent être bien faits
peuvent être faits sécuritairement je
pense que c'est pour mon père qui
doivent nous empêcher de réaliser nos
rêves nos peurs ça vire souvent des
choses qu'on connaît trop bien et donc
en transformant les connus inconnus ont
fini à faire disparaître nos peurs mais
oui parfois aussi ils certaine peur
conoco choix de confronter moi cette
part-là vient du fait qu un jour je suis
pareil j'ai rencontré un aventurier et
lui est parti en expédition et caen qui
est revenu ces deux enfants étaient
morts de deux causes différentes
je sais qu'il ya peu de chances que ça
m'arrive mais là j'ai personne à qui en
parler tranquillement chemine avec cette
idée là puis finit par modique et quand
j'ai pris mes deux enfants dans mes bras
va partir statut la dernière fois de ma
vie que je les prenais dans mes bras et
cette idée là
assez mis en vente et au point où ce que
j'ai vraiment vraiment connu des ravages
cahors
je sais que je parlais que ceux
d'aujourd'hui
qui
est ce que tu peux prendre des filles
glissez est très fort
et j'ai appelé mon ami max puis max m'a
dit fred pas choisi d'être là profites
en je me suis un moment une garde c'est
bon tu reviens d'antoine antarctique
mais j'ai compris que ce que max voulais
dire c'est que lui et moi on a la même
croyance dans vie on croit tous les deux
que dans la vie on peut soit je suis
choisir ou soit subie choisie ou subie
j'avais choisi d'être là et c'était à
moi de choisir mon attitude par rapport
à ce qui m'arrivait on peut pas choisi
tout ce qui nous arrive c'est impossible
et on peut au moins choisi notre
réaction par rapport à ce qui nous
indigne ça c'est l'attitude bien tu te
bats on a tous le choix de sous
j'ai décidé de prendre mon anti 2 puis
de l'utiliser pour changer mes pensées
je savais que j'avais aucun contrôle sur
mes émotions mais je savais que j'avais
contrôle sur les pensées qui générait
mes émotions mais j'ai décidé de maféré
a changé une pensée à la fois
tranquillement pour changer ma situation
j'ai décidé de me projeter dans des
endroits où est ce que je suis plus
heureux sur terre puis cet endroit là
c'est quand je suis avec mes enfants
j'ai décidé de me concentrer à imaginer
être avec mes enfants j'ai skié pendant
des heures avec eux autres jiri avec eux
et j'ai pleuré lequel je leur ai demandé
d'être prudente
je leur ai dit pourquoi j'étais là puis
je leur ai dit que je serais prudent
pique je reviendrai à la maison le plus
rapidement possible
j'ai skié avec mes enfants j'ai skié
avec ma femme j'ai skié avec mes amis
mes parents et de moments extrêmement
souffrent que je vivais là j'ai réussi
en a tiré des leçons des victoires j'ai
réussi à changer mon attitude du russe à
faire disparaître ma part à partir du
moment où on réalise qu'on a le pouvoir
sont notre attitude qui existe des
techniques pour passer à travers les
conflits les difficultés les plus graves
devient tellement plus fort mentalement
les écrans
j'ai atteint mon objectif
un jour
j'ai atteint mon objectif à prendre fin
un jour et quelques heures j'ai réussi à
changer mes pensées et en fait ce sont
mon message que je pour vous osez
l'aventuré penser à l'action mais
surtout ayez des objectifs audacieux
diviser leurs petites étapes en petit
objectif réalisable
les gens qui ont des défis dans la vie
sont les gens qui sont plus heureux
qu'ils sont plus en santé et qu'ils
vivent plus longtemps ce mot en haut
comme trois bonnes raisons d'avoir des
défilés je vous laisserai sur une pensée
qui m'ont aidé à l'asie ce projet là qui
met dans tous mes projets en fait et
cette pensée dit que les plus grands
obstacles à nos réalisations de demain
son no doubt d'aujourd'hui comment qu'on
réussit à vaincre le dot avec l'antidote
merci beaucoup mais je vois tous ne
veulent pas d'après midi